Layla had a bunch of dudes who were
always hollering even on like her
birthday I think she got like two gifts
from other dudes I was like they were
trying to you she was like no
they're just friends I was like guys are
not going to be friends with girls to be
friends with them I was like if they
want to have a friend they'll go find a
guy this was like an ongoing like not in
a malicious way but it was like almost
like a joke throughout like the early
days before we got married the day she
changed her marital status all of them
befriended her and I was like just
saying it was just like oh you're so so
great awesome stuff like whatever like
neutral comments and I was like these
guys are not your friends they're
planting seeds and hoping someday that
it'll sprout